we always find these fascinating studies
about porn habits in the United State
what state is watching what a lot of
weird stuff in the South usually but we
found one based on political
partisanship Democrats versus
Republicans what porn they're watching
and this was a study done by BuzzFeed
they teamed up with the fine folks over
at pornhub.com and let's see what they
found out so Democrats are watching more
porn than Republicans I was surprised we
think that Republicans are hiding in
their room watching the weird porn and
they are just a teeny bit like just it's
it's not a huge so this is pageviews per
capita over 12 months study there's a
13% difference so Democrats are watching
13% more porn let's look at the top
right states
this is pageviews per capita we have
someone from Kansas how does that make
you feel proud very very proud yeah let
it fly man what do you think's going on
in Kansas that they're watching so much
boy I don't know I was actually shocked
by this because I love the good people
of the great state of Kansas the
breadbasket the Great Plains if you will
yeah it is where I hail from geographic
center of the United States of America
literally yeah the Heartland and I know
many Kansans that uh pretty pretty
pretty boring huh so this actually
almost like they don't get out a lot
because they're too busy jerkin it's
important but I was actually really
surprised by this I don't I don't think
there's really anything wrong with you
know people watch and porn so if they if
my people want to do that I think god
bless I also don't think there's
anything wrong with watching porn let's
look at the top blue states of course
Blue means Democratic if you're a new to
this game Nevada yes from being around
Harry Reid he's so boring that these
people feel like they need boring or
super hot
anonyme Illinois Colorado Massachusetts
etc etcetera the Colorado Colorado which
inexplicably borders Kansas which just
that's weird it doesn't make it outside
right Colorado Kansas that nobody really
inhabits yeah and the part of Colorado
that nobody thinks is Colorado
connection you got to go like 300 miles
in Colorado before you see a freaking
amount and but but I figure in Kansas
it's it's very cold and it's it's it's
flat and there's nothing to stop the
wind and the cold that so people stay in
to watch porn and then when it's not
cold when it's nice out you go outside
and you're like oh they're still [ __ ]
nothing to do well then they just go
back go back inside yeah yeah but
Colorado surprises me because it's you
know it's outdoors and vigorous and
exciting in the American West are you
guys surprised the Democrats watch more
important even though it's only 13%
there's only so much you can glean out
of studies like this but it isn't it
surprising like it seemed like the first
study where you think that it's gonna
turn out the Conservatives watch more it
didn't get out that way yeah I'm a
little surprised because it turns out
the people who you think would watch
more porn they're more sort of sexually
progressive and open are the people who
watch more right we always think it's
the worst the other way well yeah you're
right we thought I think we all thought
this was gonna come out of like
repression and like ah ha ha ha right
like it turns out you know there's
probably some truths if you're a little
more liberal you're probably a little
more liberal with your joystick you
don't you know a lot of us believe and
say and Young Turk shows all the time
that that you know I think the most anti
gay congressman of the most strongly
anti-gay people are probably secretly
gay I really don't I sell them by that I
don't think I just think they're their
unsecret ly hateful yeah
so I don't think there's some like I
don't think they go home and you have
loftier ambitions I do I just think
they're bad people I don't think they're
trying to I don't think they're hiding
something I just think they can we at
least pretend that the majority of the
Kansans
staying home and yanking it to porn are
all in the Westboro Baptist Church
compound oh that would be nice to them
for the purposes of this segment we sure
can we can yeah
we'd have I'd be remiss if we didn't
talk about independence in a porn study
about this what do you think the
independence are they watching a lot of
porn they're clearly masturbating alone
are they they got they got to be right
in the middle yeah they're right in the
middle so they're just they're right
they're not as much as the Democrats not
as little as the Republican yeah they're
probably you know what I bet they're as
much as the Democrats because there's
some degree of repression happening with
Republicans that just won't let them do
it even in the privacy of it but they're
independent they don't care what you
think they'll do whatever they want
they'll sit there all day and
independents are basically gutless and
unwilling to make an important decision
in their lives all right
[Music]